[Applause]
please welcome one of my favorite
actresses on planet earth in the history
elizabeth
[Applause]
it's so good to see you oh my god i'm so
happy
it's been way too long it has been way
too long and this is the dream like over
here in person an irl as the kids say
[Applause]
are you comfortable
[Laughter]
all right so
you are in um
is it true that you're in season five
right now of the handmaid's right now
right now
and i
love where it's going
oh there's just we are all human and
when people have been wronged we want to
make it right yes and it's like and it's
just delicious and fighty and fighty and
everything what's going on how's the
season going any spoilers
uh it's going really well we're halfway
through uh-huh she's already because i
haven't said anything you're already
excited
my favorite show ever thank you
um i will say that it's a it's a very
big season we've been on location a lot
we've been in the studio very little um
which for us means that it's very big
and we're we're just constantly on the
road a lot of locations june's journey
is big the other characters journeys are
very big um and june's dealing with what
does freedom actually mean
you know and and
can she really be free and what does
that mean and where do i place my anger
and and these really big questions that
i think are also really identifiable yes
you know it's so true
what does whoa
okay well in your new project which is
another example of your immaculate work
and performance and style it's
quintessential if you love elizabeth
moss this show is for you shining girls
tell us about that show yes it's very
very twisty very twisty it's one of
those shows that the first episode you
think what you know and then the second
episode you're like oh no it's
completely different and then the third
and fourth and so on and so forth um so
i play kirby who is works at the chicago
sometimes she's an archivist in 1992
uh which was really fun and
she has survived a brutal assault six
years prior to when our show begins so
that's like one side of the show and
then there's another side of the show
which is she's dealing with an
ever-shifting reality and i mean quite
literally yeah like things change around
her and she doesn't know why so the show
is actually about her figuring out how
and why
and there's things that match up to
things that happen that give her
revelations and it goes on a ride from
there and it is so good it is a roller
coaster ride thank you i appreciate that
[Music]